Good afternoon.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It's my great pleasure to introduce local author,
local to Boston.
Heidi peddler.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for coming.
Hi.
Pleasure.
No,
our pleasure.
mine.
Look,
we'll just go.
Actually this is Heidi.
Second time here.
She was here last week for David to cuff me.
Those are,
yes.
Um,
who they worked for nine years as an editor at Houghton Mifflin.
since then she's worked for another nine years as co editor of the best American
short stories of the year.
So you've probably read more short fiction,
at least American short fiction than anybody else probably anywhere can claim.
I hope
so.
If anyone else has sort of reads and more,
I think they need help.
I need help.
So they definitely mean
she's a little sort of a fun time to wrote two novels,
the birthdays and her most recent novel,
which you have copies of the day,
like marriage,
which are road and advance.
And I'm in another month or two,
I may recover from reading.
That's pretty strong stuff should be available only with the prescription or the
people
over.
I Dunno what 18,
16,
14.
It's um,
it's seriously,
it's powerful stuff.
So with no further ado,
Heidi,
thank you again for having me.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
Um,
I thought I would read,
well I'll,
I'll sum up the book for you and I thought I would read a few pages just to give
you a sense of it and then maybe we can talk about it or anything else you might
want to talk about today.
Um,
so this novel is about a married couple.
They've been married for a long time.
Um,
they have a 15 year old and an eight year old,
15 year old daughter named Janine and an eight year old son named Ethan.
Um,
their marriage has grown,
strained.
They are not super thrilled with each other anymore and the book starts out with
them getting into an argument,
a heated,
you know,
your typical married couple being pushed to the extreme argument.
Um,
so where I'm going to start is,
uh,
the,
the characters names are level level is the husband and Hannah is the wife.
Um,
they have just finished their argument.
Hannah has run off into the son's room.
Whose name is Ethan and I'm going to read,
um,
levels.
We're were,
we're level now.
Uh,
the aftermath of the fight,
the,
the moments after in his mind,
he faced pillow bunched into a ball and it's ivory case at the far corner of the
mattress,
the poison that they had kept stored away inside themselves.
This toxic stew that had expanded for years had finally boiled over and out.
Janine pushed the door,
open an inch and leaned her face forward.
She peered around the room,
her hair sat in a brutalized tangle at the top of her head.
You all done?
She asked.
Yes.
He said unable to face her right now.
Let's get you back to sleep.
You managed.
If he was able to seem calm and steady,
she might believe that he was,
I wasn't sleeping.
She said,
keeping herself behind the door as he approached.
Of course not,
I'm sorry.
That was no good.
He had learned that the more he tried to explain away their battles to her,
the worst they sounded.
Where's mom?
She asked.
Hannah slept in Ethan's room whenever he had trouble sleeping,
which was most nights probably in your brothers room.
Janine stuffed,
careful stepped carefully around the door and in front of him.
Is She okay?
She asked his daughter could be surprisingly maternal toward Hannah.
Your mother's fine.
He said automatically I'm fine too.
Yeah,
to not that she had asked.
He followed her to her bedroom.
He talked to her in,
although she flinched at his touch and then he sat beside her on her mattress.
At last she closed her eyes.
He stayed a moment looking down at his daughter,
the wisps of light hair across her temple.
Her lips barely parted as she lay there on her side.
She may not have been sleeping.
She may have been pretending,
but he did not say anything.
He was grateful that she allowed this right now,
that she was letting him just stay here and look at her.
The early days.
Those first few months of friendship when all that he knew of Hanaman row fit
inside a daydream.
She had grown up on Martha's vineyard and now lived alone and one of her parents
to off island homes if four bedroom brownstone on Clarendon,
we're a tree size grandfather clock stood guard just inside the front door.
She kept a rosewood box of verdicts,
honey caramel truffles on our coffee table at all times.
She collected antique glass perfume bottles that were rounded and spiny.
Swirled with primordial indigo and deep opaque emerald.
She was passionate about the red sox but hated the PA,
hated the Patriots and football in general.
She gave the impression of a swan regal but fragile,
lovely and thoughtful and capable of sudden wildness.
She was the most feminine,
self assured compelling female that he had ever met.
She called him one night with a ticket to a game against the Blue Jays.
The next afternoon my friend just backed out.
I'd have called you sooner.
She began,
he immediately accepted and because she had a car and he did not,
they agreed that she would come pick them up before the game.
The next afternoon she arrived at his apartment in Brighton wearing a ski.
Her next swaddled in lumpy Harry scarf.
Her nostrils were pink and inflamed and she sounded congested.
Had he missed it over the phone,
he let her inside and offered to make her some tea.
We don't have to leave the second,
do we?
He asked.
No,
she shrugged.
Not just yet.
He hung up her jacket while she unraveled her scarf.
He filled a mug with water and put it in the microwave.
They sat across from each other at the wobbly card table in his kitchen down the
hall.
His roommate,
Paul labored with his trombone scales,
unable to reach the higher notes.
Hannah's hair pulled down onto her shoulders and ran over her small breasts down
over her stomach,
stopping at her waist.
She had these light filled eyes and a black eyelash clung to the side ridge of
her nose.
She made considerable attempts to sniff back.
All that was inside her sinuses.
He went to find a box of tissues and when he returned he asked you,
sure,
you're up for a baseball game outside.
I'll be fine.
The season's almost over.
We have to go.
Thanks.
She said as she reached for the box,
she asked,
have you ever been in love her crazy questions always nonsequitors still
blindsided him?
I'm not sure.
I don't think so.
He said Paul groaned and started again at the beginning of the scale.
The microwave beeped and level found a box of Lipton that Paul's mother had left
on her last visit level,
set the mug down before Hannah and she brought it to her.
Mel for a dainty sip,
the table tottered beneath her arms and she wrapped her fingers around the Mug
to protect the teeth or her lap.
He found an empty box of frosted flakes with the recycling,
folded it into awkward fourths and jammed it under the shortest table leg.
Once he took his seat again,
she looked off beyond him.
So what exactly does it feel like?
He said at last,
Oh,
you'd know,
she said that's what they always say.
You just know.
He said the trombone grew louder,
a whiny,
embarrassing little brother in the next room.
I'm here.
The first night I met him,
we slept together.
She said this jerk named Doug bone had been her fiance just a few months ago.
She talked about him a lot and the next night too,
she said,
I probably shouldn't admit that.
How to respond.
Anyway,
level had a chemical oceanography paper due the next day.
He should have been finalizing his isotope indicators,
proofreading.
He had a hundred things he should have been doing other than sitting here with
this girl.
She said,
you've never done that.
Slept with someone right away.
She made one last heartbreaking attempt to breathe through her nose.
He had,
but he didn't think it was love,
nothing like that.
What's the right answer?
He said,
there's no right or wrong.
She said,
well,
I guess there was this one girl and we almost did.
We got really close.
He said,
but I didn't want to hurt her later on,
so I held off.
I mean,
we both did a the right answer.
Anyway.
She said he watched her guide the tea bag around the water by its paper tag.
He was a Gawky long limbed phd candidate from Semi Rural Maine.
He was allergic to shellfish and in his rare time,
rare free time,
he did little other than monopolize his roommate's Nintendo.
She was light years out of his league.
Now the wrong answer,
she said,
yes.
We went ahead and slept together,
but I didn't really love her.
He said,
tell me more.
She said she,
he began a section of his chest whether he felt protective of it.
No,
no.
She said he shook his head.
Good for you.
She said and nodded.
Really?
It's not in my business.
She finished her tea and drew a deep breath this time through her mouth.
She sat up straighter and looked at him a new as if only now realizing he was in
the room with her level and not someone else.
You are a good person,
aren't you?
She said,
I try.
He said she studied his face side to side,
up and down.
I could use a good person.
I need someone good in my life right now.
She said good.
He said,
sadly he had landed on that brotherly side of the spectrum.
Oh,
she said,
oh,
what?
His face was hot.
It was too late.
Nothing she said carefully,
but she half smiled,
embarrassed,
maybe,
hopefully intrigued.
Are we ready to go
now?
Level checked one more time to see whether both cars are in the driveway.
When he saw that they were,
he had it downstairs for his laptop and answered some work emails.
There would be no point trying to fall asleep after this night.
He skimmed the newspaper,
considered finding his Banjo,
which he had not played in a few years.
He flipped through some magazines.
He eventually made his way back upstairs and into bed.
Later he heard the Meccan,
her kid on this bike outside and the smack of newspapers landing on driveways as
well as the sound of the milk trucks screeching down winter street.
That compact joyless bovine woman,
Hannah's term.
It had made him how,
who left bottles of organic milk on people's porches once a week in the morning.
Hannah remains steely for the brief time that he saw her before he had to leave
for work,
but she allowed him to give her a quick kiss goodbye and he helped.
This might be a precursor to a truce.
He turned his thoughts to all that lay ahead of him at his office.
The numbers from Pago pago would screw up as estimates of potential intensity of
tropical cyclones.
Hurricane Katrina had garnered him and his theory some attention,
but still there were plenty of naysayers in the government level arrived at mass
environmental and the day began.
Thank you.
Well,
thank you for that.
Sure.
Luvo pros.
Oh,
thank you.
So I'm curious,
I'd like to get into the differences between short fiction and extended
novelist,
but you've spent most of your career at this point are a significant part of it.
Basically judging short fiction.
Yes.
When you were an editor at Houghton Mifflin to do work a lot with short fiction
or did you sort of just sort of stumble into short fiction?
Well,
I think,
you know,
before I worked at Houghton Mifflin,
I got my Mfa at Emerson College.
And most writing students start out by studying short fiction.
And because it's a very work shoppable form,
it's a very digestible for them.
Um,
so I guess I started with short stories and that might've been my true love.
when I became an editor,
I did work on short story collections and novels.
I did a little nonfiction,
but,
um,
because I worked with a lot of new writers,
that tends to be the foreign people start out with.
So I did some of them.
Um,
and it's the,
you know,
a story collection is not the preferred form.
It wasn't then.
It's not.
Now publishers kind of say,
that's great.
Do you have a novel after that?
Um,
so that is,
uh,
you know,
tends to be the way to get some writers in the door.
Um,
I was an assistant but worked on a book called the interpreter of maladies.
Oh,
sure.
And,
um,
it was so gratifying to see that this was a story collection.
We published it as paperback original.
It was a very modest acquisition and it doesn't matter what form it is.
Writing.
Great writing I think is great writing and I still feel that way.
Um,
I,
you know,
my day job is short fiction.
My writing is longer fiction,
but um,
in my mind it's,
they're almost interchangeable.
I think,
you know,
it's,
it's more about the writing to me and the pros and the quality of it then the,
the form that it comes in.
Yeah.
I've always imagined,
I've never gone through writing programs,
so I could be completely misinformed,
but I've always imagined that the short story as a form always require,
has always required a different skillset or always has its own set of rules as
opposed to longer fiction.
Is there any truth to that?
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's such a different feeling too,
right?
I think I,
I always say writing a novel is like at the beginning of writing a novel,
you walk into a big empty house and you think,
I had to fill all these rooms.
And when you're writing a story,
you're in a room and you,
you know,
usually you can see at least one or two walls,
a closet,
you know,
kind of what the [inaudible] you can sense what the parameters are.
Um,
I think in novels,
so many new writers stumble when they are over ambitious and you think,
I've got to fill this whole damn house.
I,
you know,
let's throw in it.
Let's throw in some history.
Let's throw in a lot of characters.
I think you see a lot of novelists really stuffing it full because of that fear.
When you walk in that fear of emptiness,
of white space on the page,
um,
I'm forgetting what your question was.
Just fine.
Differences in both potentially both the form of a strong story and the skills
required to produce both forms.
You know,
there are different than,
I do think writers tend to either fall on one side of the,
the,
the wall or the other.
You're either a short story writer or a novel writer.
In short stories,
obviously every word matters more.
Um,
there's not the room for tangents and aggressions that there is an in novels.
you know,
the flip side of that is in novels,
there's that,
there's a lot of space to fill it.
You know,
I think,
um,
it was really interesting writing this book because it's short and it's,
I think kind of tight.
There's there,
you know,
I,
I cut away a lot of the,
the digressions that were in there earlier.
Um,
maybe this is kind of a hybrid or what's called a novella,
but,
um,
it's being published as a novel.
Um,
so yeah,
if there's a different,
there's,
I'm not sure if I'd say it's different skill set or a different mindset.
I think it's a very different mindset and some people are more comfortable in
one.
And then in the other,
um,
I've seen a lot of story writers make the transition awkwardly.
I've seen a lot of novelists,
you just try and squeeze themselves into short stories and I,
you can tell a lot of times,
granted that's my job and all I do is read stored stories and I'm very critical
of this stuff.
But I do think you can tell where people's comfort level is.
Okay.
[inaudible] speaking.
No,
I won't identify the person,
but I know there's at least one person in this room who's an aspiring fiction
writer.
Good.
Um,
you mentioned that at Houghton Mifflin at least,
I assume most publishers that if I understood correctly,
it's easier to get published as a novelist and as a short story writer.
What advice would you give the aspiring writer of fiction?
Because I can also imagine going the route of publishing short stories and
journals in a McSweeney's in different places and then possibly having done
that,
you know,
outlining a novel,
workshopping that and going to a publisher and saying,
Hey,
I have these short story credits.
You know,
here are three chapters and an outline.
What do you think are going to an agent?
So I mean,
is that a legit,
that's the standard route is to write short stories,
to try to get them published and then,
or win some awards or do some residencies.
There are all these great writing centers,
Grub Street in Boston,
there's bread loaf,
there's a lot of different residencies.
And programs you can apply to.
So to sort of go that route to writing short stories,
gather some credits,
um,
try to find an agent,
you know,
put together a collection.
Usually it'll be asked to write a novel.
Um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a big fan of,
I don't think breaking rules as much as following what it is that you really
want to,
right.
So if you want to write stories,
by all means go that route.
It's not easy to get stories published.
I'm not sure why exactly that is.
There's a ton of literary magazines out there,
but it's really hard to get stories published.
I,
you know,
I've talked to umpteen writers when I used to write stories,
I had a hard time finding people to publish them.
Um,
it's a,
it's a funny world and I'm not sure if it's because a lot of the magazines are
published by universities.
So you get Grad students reading the piles of,
uh,
stories that come in and they,
you know,
might not have a sense of if a story is trying to take a risk,
you see less risky stuff out there.
And some of the journals.
But to go back to the question,
I think it's important to figure out what you really want to write.
If you want to write,
you know,
a science fiction novel and that is your end goal,
screw it.
Get to that.
You know,
if you want to write a prose poem and that's what you know,
you have to find where that energy is,
where that thing that keeps you interested is there.
It's hard these days who wants to write?
There's so much to distract us.
You would Google should know this.
Um,
it's,
you know,
the whole world is full of attention thieves.
So you have to find what is just gripping to you and,
and allow yourself to write that.
I think no matter what it is,
um,
there's always going to be prescribed routes to go about this and that.
And then you hear these stories of people,
you know,
the most successful people didn't go that route.
J K Rowling,
you know,
people who sort of wrote on the sly.
I think,
again,
the key is to figure out what works for you and to respect your own inner voice
in a way.
It's a hard thing to do these days,
but I think it's important.
Okay.
No.
In terms of the best American short fixed move a year,
you typically work with well known writers most recently to a surprise winner,
Jennifer Egan to produce those.
MMM.
Do they pull their weight or they're just big names to put up the covers?
You don't have to answer that honestly.
How does the process work?
They definitely pull their weight.
I mean I have a different way.
So what I do is I get,
I read everything that's published in a calendar year by an American journal
that is distributed,
which encompasses a huge amount.
Um,
I read between three and 4,000 a year.
So I'm really picky and critical and awful.
I'm kind of your worst nightmare reader because I have kids and I write and I
don't,
I have no patients.
So either,
you know,
I'm with you on page one or two or forget it.
Um,
so I read all these stories.
They all get sent to me.
They've,
they've,
they just come in,
I'm on everybody's list circulation list.
I read them all.
I pull 100 and of them.
And then I said those as to my guest editor who pulls 20,
they pick 20.
And everyone's different.
We work together sometimes more,
sometimes less.
Um,
they're the big name.
I let them decide how the process should go.
But,
um,
it's,
it's the world's greatest job.
It really is.
It's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
I get to be in a one on one book club with just an incredible,
an incredibly successful and talented writer every year and have it be someone
different.
Um,
it's,
it's fascinating.
It's completely,
completely fascinating.
Their processes are all different.
Um,
I never know what to expect.
When I started this job.
I thought,
oh,
I'm going to,
you know,
Lsd bold,
who wrote the lovely bones.
I pulled all these stories and,
you know,
violent stories about kids and girls and none of them,
she just,
you know,
she was really into historical fiction and I thought,
oh,
this is,
I have no idea.
You know?
So then I began to just sort of say we need to,
I just need to rely on my gut,
pick things that I like,
not try to please the other person,
which is such a good life lesson.
Some sometimes and,
and yeah,
it's really unpredictable each year,
but there's a lot of reading and,
and they do a lot of reading too.
They have to read 120 of these stories and pick 20 and some years it's easier
than others.
There's a lot,
there can be a lot of back and forth between us.
Sure.
But ultimately the 20 for a perk or other ones that will go in the book.
Yes,
yes.
And they're,
and they're the,
they write a foreword.
I ride,
I ride a forward,
they write an introduction and they're the ones who,
it's kind of Nice for me because if people complain about the stories,
I say,
well lamb,
Jenny Egan,
I had nothing to do with it.
Nice.
Not to have the full load rest on me.
Sure.
Always good to have a backup.
Yes.
Well,
anything else you want us to know about everything else you do?
Oh my God,
I blow.
Okay.
Everybody sit back.
Um,
I don't think so.
Do you guys have any questions?
Maybe that it's always,
I always like knowing what you want to hear so I'm not yammering into the ether
so much.
So go ahead.
Yeah,
some reviews and the block and
very hard under either in a sense,
and I read it before and also a little bit of a lot of readers can relate to
both them to argue
or something or arguments
usually doesn't go that path as well.
But this is like leaving out like nothing off the feminist reading about some
characters and see what happens is,
this might be already already the lesson for us.
Even
they source reading.
I was wondering what made you choose such an intense emotional subject?
Um,
how did your weight,
your risk of having something that readers to recover from
and also how did you cope,
emotional burden of having to,
to be in the position of having to ride it out and go back over and over and
reliving what we are doing and what did it mean for
the ride.
Right.
Um,
so a few answers.
so I wrote my first book,
it was published in 2006 and it is a novel about a family full of pregnant
people.
Um,
and it's kind of a family drama.
It's set on an island in Maine.
And after I published it,
some well known writer came up to me and he said,
you know what?
I love what,
you know,
what I love about a book?
And I said,
what?
He said,
well,
I usually like when something happens.
And I said,
wow,
thanks.
I just kind of turn purple and crept away.
But it stuck with me and I thought it,
you know,
it was,
I love my first book,
but it doesn't have a huge plot.
It was more of a psychological exploration of a family.
And I thought I wouldn't mind writing,
uh,
like a big bang book,
just where,
you know,
it had something really,
it's always been important to me,
and this sounds really basic,
but to keep your reader turning pages,
it's a really fundamental thing.
I think a lot of readers lose sight of that.
Once again,
these days.
There are so many distractions out there.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of people aren't reading as much as as they used to and it's important to
keep your reader engaged.
So I had that in the back of my mind after my first book.
Um,
I got pregnant with twins and my husband and I lived out in a small town and I
took this new job and I was just kind of homebound with twins,
um,
and it,
which was really hard on me.
We were isolated and we were kind of out what felt like out in the middle of
nowhere.
Um,
it was a strange place to be at.
All I knew is I wanted to write something that had a big story.
And around this time there was,
um,
the Lacy Peterson story was in the news a lot.
And I started noticing there's all these stories of these very beautiful women
who go missing and it's something grizzly happens to them and why,
why are they getting so much coverage?
Why are these stories getting so much coverage?
So I kind of dipped a toe in this story.
And then soon,
maybe a month later,
um,
a woman who lived in my town of was shot.
She and her baby or her young baby were shot in her bed by her British husband
and the press just flooded into our town.
And I was like a crazy person.
I was completely obsessed with this.
They lived less than a mile and a half from us.
Um,
our town center,
a nice little bucolic town,
green filled up with reporters.
And I watched this whole thing and I,
it just kind of got under my skin and I thought,
what is with this?
Why,
why has this become a dark fairy tale for us?
Why do we,
why does,
why do people lap this up?
The media,
the readers,
why do I care?
You know,
I've sort of a smart person.
I'm literary,
I don't,
you know,
usually read in tabloid news so much,
but I could not get enough of this case.
So I,
that was my indoor to this story.
I had these things swirling around in my head,
um,
and I started writing it.
And the darker story was really part of a backstory.
As I was writing the first few drafts,
it was,
uh,
there was a nicer,
happier story around it,
which eventually fell away.
Um,
with the help of my editor who saw that the book really was about the darker,
more uncomfortable story and it was okay to let that sit alone on the page.
Um,
I didn't set out for it to be this emotional and this intense,
I think it needed to be,
it's a weird thing as a writer,
um,
and it probably sounds a little bit crazy,
but a book needs to be a certain thing.
Your characters speak to you in a way that can override what your needs are.
And so this thing kind of took over my life for so long.
It was very painful to write,
but it was also when I had finished it in the way that it needed to be finished,
it was incredibly rewarding.
And I felt nervous because I thought,
Oh God,
I'm going to send this dark thing out into the world.
But I also thought of many other dark books that did okay.
I think people can handle intensity and I think it's important,
um,
to trust your reader.
I think I'm not enough,
you know,
people in various businesses do.
And I think people at the end of the day want to be moved.
They want Catharsis and they're reading.
So maybe this was all just justification,
but I clung to it and now we have this book.
So if that answers that.
Any other questions?
Anything anyone wants to talk about?
Actually,
I have one morning just touched on them and taking off your question.
Um,
certainly there are at least a few superficial similarities to another dark
book.
You know where I'm going with this,
which has got no idea where,
well,
you might've heard there was a book that was on the Times bestseller list for
about 19 or 20 years,
seemingly called gone girl that we might've made a little movie about it.
And there,
there are few,
at least superficial resemblances between your book and that one.
Is that something that
came up during the editing process or the publishing process with you?
That's a great question.
So,
um,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
So this book took me along,
time to write and gone.
Girl was published,
I'm not sure what year,
but a few years into my writing it and I thought,
Oh,
you know,
I don't,
I read it.
And right away I thought this is such a different book.
I think gone girl is an edgy,
wonderful mystery thriller,
um,
fonder kind of ride of a book.
Mine has been called a mystery or thriller and I don't really think it is.
I think it's suspenseful.
And I think,
I feel,
I always feel a little pretentious using the words literary,
but I think it's literary and suspenseful and psychological,
but it's not,
um,
it's,
it's not gone girl in any way.
I mean the first five pages,
maybe there's a similar premise,
but it goes in such a wildly different direction.
That said,
it's been hard having that out there.
It feels like the person in the room,
you know,
the,
the 800 pound gorilla that's hanging out with me during this whole time.
I'd love gone girl.
I thought it was wonderful.
I loved the movie.
Um,
this isn't that book.
And I think people keep the,
there's a lot,
there's a lot of desire out there to say this is the next gone girl or this is
the next whatever big book out there.
And you know,
as a writer you can't pay attention to that,
you know,
unless it is the same book.
Once I had read it I felt better.
But yeah,
there have,
there's been a lot of comparisons made in the press and,
and I worry that that together when there's a lovely quote from Stephen King on
the front,
I worry that the gone girl comparison together with this great Stephen King
quote is going to mislead people.
So,
um,
but at the end of the day,
I guess that's not my job.
My job is to write a book and worry about the writing.
And then at this point it's,
it's yours,
it's,
it's for the readers.
And I go away and shield myself a little bit,
hopefully.
Um,
so that's what I'll say about that.
Okay,
fair enough.
Renewed.
You know,
I do and I am always nervous to talk about it too soon,
but I do and it's much lighter.
I kind of feel like I need a vacation after this one.
Um,
and I worry it might be so like that.
There'll be no,
you know,
if there's a reader that likes us,
they won't like that.
But again,
you can't care about,
you have to just write what you want to ride.
So,
um,
I just,
my,
my main idea is that it's about happiness and the search for happiness,
which will probably mean it'll turn into something horrible and unhappy knowing
me.
But I'm going to try,
I need a lighter experience.
Anything else?
Any other questions?
Go ahead.
We will.
Description of your job.
You seem to read six,
seven,
eight hours a day.
Yeah.
Which brings me to a question when you should do,
when I finish a book,
the short story more in the novel,
I did take a few,
it doesn't matter what it is about,
you just need to up pay my respect to the book,
but just waiting for a few days before I switch to another book.
I was wondering how you managed to do this context switching so fast,
five times a day.
I know.
So I have to do many switches or pallet cleansers like call them and this is
what's made me an absolute Twitter and Facebook junkie because it's the perfect
amount of time.
You know,
I'll read a story if I read the holster.
So if I read a whole story,
my computers there putz around on Twitter and Facebook for a bed,
get the mind out because I can't afford to take a longer chunk of time.
There's just too much to read.
Um,
at the end of my reading year,
I've always,
it always is this avalanche and no matter how much I try and stay on top of it
through the year,
there's just this neuro and pile that is sitting there at the end of the year.
And there's,
there's a few less,
you know,
pallet cleansers in there and you just,
you learn to do it after awhile,
but you also learn to sort of accept the fact that now you're human,
that you're not perfect.
And you know,
I always feel kind of like,
you just feel strange about how am,
who am I to decide what the best American short story is.
At some point all of us just say,
well,
I'm going to do the best I can and I'm going to accept my shortcomings.
And um,
there are days where I'm in a bad mood and unfortunately if I'm reading your
story that's,
you know,
that's the way the world works.
Like any job,
there are days where my kids are driving me crazy or our second I have to read
with
the TV blaring and the,
you know,
the water pipes broken or something.
And I've sort of the,
you know,
I'm going into my 10th volume so I've learned to forgive myself and a lot of
ways and at least try to accept my imperfections on the job.
Um,
but that said,
Twitter and Facebook are,
or my friends for Palette cleansing.
Anyone else have any other questions?
Go ahead.
Between the two
cds were reading it or doing all three
but the main one here where like where ideas from one environment to the other.
Absolutely.
I think the best thing to do was to write first in the day.
I dropped my kids off at school and then go right.
Because if I read first,
other voices get into my head.
Um,
I try to have a time separation,
whether it's lunch,
you know,
go run an errand or something,
but it's really easy to grow to even subconsciously grab onto a voice or a
phrase or a character and have it warm it's way through without even realizing
it.
Um,
and you know,
the other thing that I think is hard is that my day job makes me a really
critical reader.
So it's hard not to be hard on myself as a writer.
Um,
it's much easier for me to revise then to produce new work.
It's hard to get it when you're in that generative space.
You have to,
it's almost like being in a dream state.
You can't,
you have to turn off every critical voice in your head or you're not going to
produce anything.
So that's gotten harder for me over the years.
Um,
and I revise this for long enough that,
um,
it's been a while.
So writing this new book feels a little bit like I've been put in a sandbox and
with no toys and I kind of have to figure it out.
It's,
it's tough,
but hopefully I'll be able to get back in the mode of it.
Any other questions,
concerns,
fears?
I have one more and one more.
Go ahead.
Cool.
Um,
okay.
I was just wondering,
I would guess two would be past this stage if it ever happened,
but at any point in this career,
have you ever had editors or agents or writers themselves say the equivalent of,
hey,
please don't read this story of mine when you know your kids are driving you
crazy or something.
I know you've read 10 stories of mine the last five years,
but this is the one,
Oh yes,
no,
people,
I have authors send me stuff and I again,
I'll read anything that was published,
so,
sure.
Um,
but they don't get to say when I read it,
I think it's like any award,
you know,
I,
it's the unfortunate luck of the draw.
I have definitely had people send me notes saying this is the best story by this
author.
And none of them are,
you know,
you can't,
you can't really take any of it in.
You have to.
Sure.
Um,
and I think I've gotten to the point where,
you know,
if I,
I used to,
my kids used to play soccer at this indoor soccer place.
It was the loudest smelliest,
nastiest space.
And I'd sit there reading my stories and all the other moms were chatting away
and I think I got really good at
yeah.
At telling right away,
this is a good story or this isn't,
you can,
it becomes this automatic thing where you just,
it's,
you know,
there's a switch flicked or not and it becomes easier and easier the more you do
it.
Um,
yeah.
But people do,
people rally a little bit,
um,
and,
and they're allowed to rally all they want,
but it's not gonna make any difference to me.
Sure.
Did you have a question,
miss somebody who's writing the story?
It sounds like you hadn't been friends for what it is that makes a good story
from like my perspective was added.
We are like,
there's always this conflict between his story that's really strong Brown.
And then the ones that just didn't vote.
One piece of imagery that no matter how little I'm enjoying get,
they're either reading two years later,
I'm still like revisiting.
Are there,
you find that correlation?
Is there an inverse correlation kind of the ones that stick with you the most?
They do.
I think I'm,
you know,
I,
I've started to think of in this very unromantic turn,
my head is a computer that's getting really stuffed.
So I don't remember as much as I used to.
Um,
when you're reading,
I also should say I'm,
um,
hoping Mifflin is publishing a book called 100 years of the best American short
stories.
And that's coming out in October.
So along with reading three to 4,000 of the regular stores a year for the past
three or four years,
I've read every volume of the book to put together this.
So this computer chip,
whatever is fried.
I mean there's just not a lot of,
you know,
specific imagery that I'm sitting around thinking up.
But um,
okay.
For my favorite stories.
It's true.
There are moments that stick with you.
There are lines that stick with you.
Um,
what do I think makes a strong story?
confident writing,
natural writing.
Um,
I wish there were more humor out there.
I like risk taking.
I'm,
I'm a big fan of melding of genres of Psi Phi,
of Dystopia or of humor mystery,
um,
as well as literary fiction.
Um,
I like anything that feels inventive or new or important or relevant.
I wish more people wrote stories about technology and science and um,
the economy,
the,
there,
there are certain,
you know,
it's funny in short fiction,
um,
news or content of the day,
it takes a while to penetrate short fiction.
So now I'm reading a lot of stories about the Iraq war,
so I always feel like I'm reading the shadow of what's happening in the real
world because it takes writers awhile to,
to digest and to properly digest what's going on in the world and make sense of
it and turned it into art,
obviously.
Um,
but yeah,
that's,
that's basically what I look for.
I think,
um,
that said good writing is good writing.
I think I'm,
I'm always surprised when I like a story that is about nothing that's just a
great voice or has great imagery or characters,
um,
that,
that is incredibly gratifying too.
Okay.
Thank you so much for coming.
This was really fun.
Thank you.